：今天我們要聊一個很有意思的創投案例。你可能會覺得，創投不就是看人、看市場、看產品嗎？但這個 VC 的做法，跟我們想像的很不一樣。
：怎麼說？難道他們不用看這些基本面了嗎？我猜啦，現在大家都說 AI，是不是又跟 AI 沾邊？
：Bingo。這是 Activate AI 的共同創辦人 Pratyush Choudhury。他們這個基金規模是 7500 萬美元，專注在 AI 領域。最讓我詫異的是，他每天光是研究跟測試 AI 模型，就要消耗掉 3 到 5 億個 tokens。
：等等，3 到 5 億個 tokens？這數字有點誇張吧。一般人怎麼可能做到？我只知道 OpenAI 那些模型會收費，這得多燒錢啊？
：其實他自己也說了，每天光是這些實驗性的花費，就要幾百到幾千美元。他之所以能撐住，是因為有朋友和公司提供大量補貼的服務。不然，他整個基金都可能燒光在學習 AI 上面。
：這點我是信了。所以他的做法，其實是把傳統創投仰賴人脈、經驗和直覺的模式，轉變成一種數據密集型的「獨角獸狩獵」系統？但光靠燒錢就能找到好的新創嗎？成本划算嗎？
：他認為，除非你「從根本上理解技術」能做什麼、不能做什麼，否則很難打造出真正偉大的 AI 公司。他每天投入這麼多資源，就是為了獲得第一手的直覺，判斷哪些技術突破是持久的，哪些只是短暫的。
：所以他具體是怎麼做到的？每天花幾百到幾千美元，燃燒數億 tokens，光是為了得到「直覺」？這怎麼量化？
：原文有提到，他會閱讀大量研究論文，並在 X 上與研究人員互動。他也會定期跟美國、歐洲、中國的 AI 研究者交流。最關鍵的是，他自己會「實作」很多技術。
：實作？意思是，他會親自去寫程式、測試模型嗎？一個 VC 應該很忙，哪有時間做這些？
：他用最前端的模型來完成幾乎所有工作，從腦力激盪活動形式、嘉賓名單，到研究新創公司，甚至在 GitHub 上實作研究論文。他用的主要是 OpenAI 的 Codex 和 Anthropic 的 Claude。
：嗯，我懂了。這不是單純的「砸錢」，而是「透過實作來深度理解」。那如果我們是一般的中小企業主或創業者，可以從中學到什麼？不可能也去燒幾百幾千美金一天吧？
：我覺得啟發點在於「深度學習」和「動手實作」。我們可能無法像他那樣燒錢，但可以把這個概念帶入自己的行業。比如說，你開一家小餐館，能不能試著用 AI 工具去分析顧客評價、菜單組合，甚至是設計新的促銷方案？
：所以是說，要放下「我覺得」或「憑經驗」，而是試著用 AI 工具去驗證、去分析？但很多 AI 工具都還是有點門檻。
：對，就是放下直覺，擁抱數據。不是要你立刻成為 AI 專家，而是思考怎麼把 AI 工具整合到日常運作。比方說，一個上班族，是不是也能用 AI 工具來整理會議記錄、分析報告數據，或是學習新的行業知識？
：這樣聽起來，這其實是提醒我們，在專業領域裡，如果只靠過去的經驗，可能很快就會被那些願意投入資源、深度理解新技術的人超越。
：沒錯。Pratyush Choudhury 其實就是用這種方式，在一個高度依賴經驗的領域裡，創造了新的競爭優勢。他們之前也成功投資了像是 Sarvam、Emergent 和 Rocket AI 這些 AI 新創。
：所以這種深度投入技術的做法，幫他們真的找到了「獨角獸」。這也提醒我們，很多時候，投入資源去理解底層邏輯，比單純追逐表面趨勢更有價值。
：嗯，好像也提醒了我們，有時候，跳脫既有框架，用一種出乎意料的方式去「動手玩」，反而可能找到新的機會。